let's talk about joy behar oh yeah she
i'm really proud of her
i'm happy for her she had a really good
take this week
columbus policeman who shot mikaya
bryant could have just
shot the gun in the air oh which is this
is great this is
that's actually the first thing any uh
concealed carry instructor will tell you
if you're not even joking i won't joke i
won't joke about this guys
do not ever do that first of all
insanity there's no such thing as a
warning shot
there is no movies guys if you fire a
gun in the air here's the thing
bullet doesn't keep going and then leave
the atmosphere
and then it doesn't like it comes back
down and people die
people have gotten hit by stray bullets
that were fired in the air don't do
they're so stupid
joy what are you talking about are you
that's like this is
you remember joe biden did you know i
was about to yeah you no
actually joel you let out two blasts
you're good no he said that yeah i
bought a shotgun
take a shotgun out you let out two
blasts
in the air right he's like fire off yes
and he said fire okay he tells his wife
she didn't need an air just get a
shotgun and fire two blasts
okay no joe to be fair if he's talking
about bird shot
you'll annoy people don't do that he was
talking about buckshot
you'll you could mildly hurt somebody
bullets you know depending on the grain
they go somewhere it's just
crazy but these these are heavier and
these can injure people seriously when
they're coming down
you don't want to fire anything into the
air because you don't know what it's
going to hit who it's going to hit what
it's going to interfere with
they land places yep in fact there are
some states where you can't actually use
certain guns for hunting because the
state's flat
so they they may have requirements about
what what weapons you can use
i think new jersey i could be wrong is
like shotguns only
because a high velocity round is going
to be it's a flat surface it's going to
travel really really far
you don't know what's going to hit you
can't track it properly
what we're hearing okay let me just
reiterate joy behar let me read you what
you said
the view co-host joy behar and sunny
hostin agreed on thursday
that the police officer who shot and
killed mikaya bryant in columbus ohio
had the option to de-escalate instead of
using deadly force
behar suggested the officer could have
just shot his gun in the air instead of
aiming at the 16 year old
quote he said the cop had no choice and
my feeling is i don't know if that's
true or not
behar said i really can't figure it out
anymore it seems to me in a situation
i've looked at the tape and i still
can't figure it out shoot the gun in the
air
warning tase a person shoot them in the
leg shoot them in the behind stop them
somehow
but if only the solution is to kill a
teenager there's something wrong with
this
lady's never been to a range in her life
never dude first of all does she think
this is a western
and like the sheriff just comes out and
fires his gun into the air and then
no no no no no she thinks the cop comes
out spins his glock
fires and it shoots the knife out of
exactly she stops
you think this is really this is really
hilarious when they say things like
shoot him
didn't joe biden say [ __ ] in the leg or
something yeah well the weapons experts
at the view
have have unfortunately let us down for
the for the first time
that i can think of i know at the view
look i understand everyone's probably
commenting saying tim doesn't know what
he's talking about with guns no no i'll
fully admit i am not a gun actor by any
means
i'm just a guy who recently bought guns
and i can tell you this lady's nuts
yeah it's kind of like but to be honest
like ripping on joy behard's view of
guns is sort of like shooting fish in a
barrel that's above your head
oh got her there am i right got jokes
that's right ladies and gentlemen she
freedom tunes all right check it out
this is why we have these insane laws
that make no sense
and i'm like you know what man i'm
sitting on twitter when people are
talking about gun control
and it's just like have you ever seen
have you
when was the last time you went to grade
school and you were just like there for
some reason you saw like all the little
kids
you know like fifth grade or whatever
and they're all really dumb
what that's rude why would you say that
because because kids
i'm not saying that to say like kids
aren't smart they lack knowledge yeah of
course
experience so you'll hear from a lot of
kids a lot of really dumb things like
it's so dumb like there's there's like
100 houses and like 10 homeless people
but like a bunch of the houses are empty
so just put the homeless people in the
houses like it's so
dumb i've seen college students share
that one right
and then you say something that's an
adult opinion apparently houses have to
be maintained and someone has to pay for
the utilities you can't just put people
under the rug and expect them to go away
but little kids say things like this
how come if there's like starving people
we just don't like give them food like
it's so
dumb tim if if we have here's the if if
we print money
why do we ever need to tax people why
don't we just print money to pay for
stuff forever
aoc advocating for deficit spending
she's like we can just print the money
to pay for them surprised yeah mmt it's
beautiful
yeah yeah so going on twitter during a
gun control argument
man wow it's just like my favorite meme
is the one where they say no
self-respecting hunter would use an
ar-15 which is not true it's the most
popular hunting rifle in the country but
not even that
but i'm like here's a photograph of an
ar-15 chambered in 450 bushmaster quite
literally for hunting
like what do you mean it's this round
was made for hunting
but these people just don't they
literally don't know anything anything
ever boy are they arrogant so they'll
tell you to do something
illegal extremely dangerous it's amazing
to me they're like the cops
should be held accountable and they
should fire their guns in the air
all right so so we've got people rioting
we've got racist police officers
and we've also got gun control like how
can we have all three at once that's why
look look that's why i'm not um i don't
understand the
the people opposed to abolishing the
place at this point because this these
cities voted for them but what do you
mean by i guess what do you mean by
abolishing the police like
i think it would be good to have a
police board so i'm i'm for some minimal
state you know let the
let the cops prevent people from
murdering each other let's clarify right
like we have a sheriff's department out
here
and they're pretty all right they're
they're they're they're
they're pretty good uh you don't have a
lot of interactions with them you call
them when you need assistance on certain
matters
and you make it pulled over by state
trooper you might be pulled over by a
sheriff's deputy or something
but it's not the same as like a police
force in a major metropolitan city
now interesting my point is it's not so
much about whether i think it's a good
deal i think it's a bad idea
i think these cities are gonna have a
lot of problems yeah i'm also
of the mind that you should have
responsibility for yourself we should
have a right to keep and bear arms
so if the left says abolish police i say
i think that's a really bad idea and
you're not going to like that and they
say
shut up bigot we're abolishing the
police i'll be like all right well
this is the thing i got in my holster
and be like you do your thing and i am
all about
demilitarizing the police but when you
turn your city into a war zone i don't
know what you expect
yeah it's interesting too because
demilitarize i guess i i brought this up
before a similar point someone kind of
they made a good point back like what
does that mean with a discussion about
militarization of the police
we see m raps we see cops in armor
and actually that's a good thing you
know why why
the more options officers have the less
lethal occurrences will happen
if an officer is fully armored and
they have less lethal rounds they have
you know sponge rounds or tear gas that
means they're not using live ammunition
that makes sense
okay that's fair if the cop also is
armored and feels like he's more likely
to be safe
he's less likely to use lethal rounds
against another person he won't fire his
gun into the air
well right so imagine you have so we i
mean we had this story just a moment ago
about these cops resigning
from their emergency response team now
they're saying they're gonna have to use
regular field officers to to fill that
gap
if you have a regular cop who's just
wearing their shirt with a vest
and they have their gun and a taser
that's it what are their options
a riot breaks out and they're like i
can't tase these people from range
and they're all throwing molotovs my
only choice is lethal force or nothing
some cops might run away okay then you
get no enforcement you give a cop a
shield
some armor and some sponge rounds and
now they're gonna
mostly nuisance people they're less
lethal because they can kill
but look it's it's it's better to have
the option
you know what i mean yeah that's fair
yeah so i i guess the idea is
when we're uh giving cops 50 bmg and all
those crazy weapons the other argument
is
what do the cops do when someone else
comes out with something like that it
doesn't mean they use it all the time
but it's interesting what people mean by
militarization i i feel like
the last time i brought that up i didn't
really thought about it i think you know
it wasn't
i was i was coming from a very ignorant
place they're less likely to make a
like a a decision out of fear probably
if they're if they're armed with the
teeth but if they're ordered to fire
then we're in way more trouble armed
teeth with what sponge rounds
i don't know also bazookas rocket
launchers but they don't have to who
knows
they don't have those things i mean do
you know what's in their trunk what's in
the apc
i really don't think they're bringing a
flamethrower
i mean weapon well hold on there's an
argument to be made for temp
flamethrowers
no of course there is yeah no no they're
actually
there's not an assistant like heavily
military wanted crew served
machine guns remember that what
yeah you remember that nancy pelosi said
in dc she wanted crew served
was it called crew service machine guns
yeah like machines
see like yeah like that's terrifying in
a city yeah it's not gonna go through a
building yeah yeah
that's insanity nancy pelosi should be
kept far away from gun laws after saying
something like that
what she thinks it's re i don't even
think that's a reason her and joy behar
i think should write the next piece of
legislation
they should get together have nancy on
the view i'm sure
i remember 1970 i wasn't there for it
but uh in may 4th 1970 at kent state
university the national guard was
ordered i don't know if they were
ordered but they fired on crowded
college kids killed four
so it's not out of the question that
cops will open fire and if they're
heavily armed
that could be devastating isn't the
point what i'm saying then is to make
sure that when they come out there they
have armor
shields and less lethal rounds that is
defensively yeah but that's not
necessarily like when you say militarize
that that's way more broad than just
shields and this is and this is a
question because i've covered this stuff
for over a decade and i've not seen an
instance
where there have been uh i i i'll put
this way
most instances when the police come out
and they're in gear and they're in
mrap's they have less lethal
there are usually one or two cops i'll
see with live ammo
we've seen those happen but for the most
part having a rifle is not
militarization
we're talking about the armor the
fatigues and the mraps and i'm like
that's actually not that big a deal cops
have had rifles since what the the 90s
when the
armor piercing bankrupt the robbers or
the armor-pressing rounds were shooting
at cops
and so then they were like we need swat
teams now they escalated tactics
but the the militarization i often see
it's like they were given an arm you
know an armored personnel carrier and
i'm kind of like
so like i don't know like what are they
gonna do they're gonna ram somebody with
it i mean they shouldn't
i think well i think that the concern
for a lot of people is a growing police
state
yeah and so that's why that frightens
them if there comes a day when the
government really does clamp down on our
rights or they come to take our guns
comes a day you say yeah if there comes
a i know if eventually at some
unthinkable point in an unforeseeable
future far down the line
um the police are weaponized against the
citizenry people are afraid of them
having
to and i totally understand that you
know i got to tell you man
when i see these donald trump supporters
and they're posting memes from michael
malus about how the police
will absolutely seize your guns from
yeah i'm like dude
the cops have lost a lot of support from
the right a lot
well especially after these right and
part of it was like in a lot of these
left wing run cities
they wouldn't really let the police do
anything to prevent the rioting
from from occurring but also they did
choose to follow those orders at the
same
time and so a lot of conservatives feel
very betrayed that's right
yeah so that's my attitude right now
right the the police out here in the
middle of nowhere the sheriffs
they alright they're cool they don't got
any beef in fact you know west virginia
is a constitutional carry
so there's no issues you can walk around
you can you can drive in your car with
your passenger like holding their weapon
you can walk down the street with your
weapon and you know the crazy thing is
nothing happens nobody's going around
like no one hurt anybody no one shoot
anybody
in fact i mentioned this before when i'm
driving through west virginia and i see
all these houses
with there's no cops anywhere and i'm
just like none of these people are
worried about getting robbed
yeah you know why the crime rates are
armed to the teeth yeah the crime rate's
actually high
wait where is this in west virginia uh
there's a lot of problem with drug use
oh okay yes what about the violent crime
rate i don't entirely know for sure
but i do know so i'm i'm in like some
facebook groups for like some west
virginia places
and there are people who are like you
know there was one someone posted
something where they were like
someone did something in my yard and
then other people were like you know
watch out because someone might be
casing the joint and then they all laugh
one guy's like man i wish it was my
house oh my gosh and i'm like calm down
gentlemen chill
chill chill there right now you don't
want to have to be in that situation
yeah you don't want to deal with
with legal laws you know what like you
want to deal with legal
lawsuits cops and all that stuff but the
attitude out there is like
don't you come on my property yeah
that's what nobody does it comes out so
it's a really interesting argument for
the anarchists to be completely honest
left or right i don't care that in these
places where people are armed
not a lot of cops thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you